TO ORDER. IN RESPONSE TO
THE CALL IN NINETEEN EMERGENCY
AND TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC THE
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS IN HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE'RE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS
HERE IN THE CAPITAL WITH SUMMER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY OUR MEMBERS ATTENDING
REMOTELY TODAY ARE SENATOR
PATROL BOAT. SENATOR AS A
REMINDER PLEASE MUTE YOUR PHONE
OR COMPUTER THIS WILL GREATLY
AID IN ELIMINATING ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. I ASK THAT EVERY TIME
YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED THAT
YOU USED TO RAISE YOUR HAND
FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM. EACH
TIME THAT YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK THE POP UP WINDOW WILL
APPEAR ASKING IF YOU WOULD LIKE.
TO BE A MUTED. PLEASE SELECT THE
I'M MUTE BEFORE. WE BEGIN
SPEAKING. R. I. T. PERSONNEL
WILL HELP PUT YOU BACK ON MUTE.
WHEN YOU ARE DONE. ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE THAT YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN
YOU'RE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC IN THE HEARING
ROOM TO THE EXTENT THE SOCIAL
DISTANCING DISTANCING.
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WE WILL
BE USING THE TELECONFERENCE ARE
WORSE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE
ARE POSTED ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. WILL ALSO BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPATION. PARTICIPANT
NUMBER. IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO
NINE ONE. SIX THREE SIX FOUR.
EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE
SIX THREE. SIX FOR AN ACCESS
CODE IS. THREE FIVE THREE ONE
TWO EIGHT THREE. AGAIN. THREE
FIVE THREE ONE TWO EIGHT THREE
FOR DETAILED DESTRUCTION
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES FROM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE OR
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL
BE PROMPTED BY THE MODERATOR TO
DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION PRESSES ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
NUMBER. THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT
ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN QUEUE FOR
THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU WILL BE
ON MUTE IT AND YOU ARE NOW READY
TO ADDRESS TO COMMIT. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE
YOUR DEVICE. THAT YOU ARE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO
GIVING YOUR TESTIMONY OVER THE
FALL IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR YOU TO HEAR FROM YOU AND WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I
WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM. DURING
THIS HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. THE DAY WE
HAVE FOUR BILLS ON OUR AGENDA.
AS B. FOUR SIX SEVEN BY SENATOR
WINNERS ON CONSENT AND S. B.
THREE FIFTY BY MELINDA'S IS VOTE
ONLY BUT BEFORE WE HEAR ANY OF
THE PRESENTATIONS WE MUST STOP
THE QUORUM CONSULTING PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. BRADFORD YOUR
RECORD HERE THE TROUBLE- BUG
HERE. COM LONGER HERE. COM
LARGER HERE SCANNER. SCANNER
HERE WINNER THERE THE CORN OKAY
THERE'S CORN HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED AND NOW WE'LL HEAR
FROM OUR FIRST AUTHOR AND- I
WILL PRESENT MY BILL AT THIS
TIME. SP THREE TO FIVE AND I
WILL HAND THE GAVEL OVER TO
SENATOR COME. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PROCEED. I'M HERE I'M HERE TO
PRESENT SP THREE TO FIVE WHICH
IS A STRAIGHTFORWARD MEASURE
THAT ADDS AN ADDITIONAL MEMBER
TO THE GANG CAL GANG DATABASE
TECHNICAL ADVISORY COMMITTEE THE
CAL GAME DATABASES MAINTAINED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IN USE
BY LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
ACROSS THE STATE TO STORE THE
NAMES OF OVER FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND PEOPLE. SUSPECTED OF
BEING ACTIVE GANG MEMBERS ARE
POSSIBLY ASSOCIATED WITH THEM
OUR RECENT STATE AUDIT FILED
THAT THE DATABASE IT INADEQUATE.
OVERSIGHT WHICH RESULTED IN
UNRELIABLE INFORMATION THAT
POTENTIALLY VIOLATE INDIVIDUALS
PRIVACY RIGHTS THIS RESULTED IN
QUESTIONABLE ENTRIES AN
INCLUSION OF INDIVIDUALS WITH NO
GANG AFFILIATION INCLUDING
CHILDREN AND ALL TOO OFTEN BLACK
AND BROWN INDIVIDUALS. THE GANG
CAL THE CAL GAME DATABASE ALLOWS
FOR AN INDIVIDUAL TO REQUEST THE
REMOVAL FOM THE DATABASE AFTER
RECEIVING NOTICE FROM LOCAL. LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES BETWEEN
OCTOBER TWENTY NINETEEN IT
SEPTEMBER TWENTY TWENTY FORTY
REQUEST FOR REMOVAL WERE MADE BY
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES IN ONLY
TEN WERE GRANTED UNFORTUNATELY
MANY INDIVIDUALS OFTEN CHOOSE
NOT TO PURSUE REMOVAL AS IT IS A
COSTLY AND TIME CONSUMING. THIS
BILL WOULD ADD AN ATTORNEY WITH
SUBSTANTIAL EXPERIENCE IN
CONTESTING THE INDIVIDUAL'S
DESIGNATION AS A GANG MEMBER TO
THE CAL GAME ADVISORY COMMITTEE.
INCLUDING THIS REPRESENTATION
WILL HELP ENSURE THE INTEGRITY
OF THE DATABASE AS WELL AS
STRENGTHENING COMMUNITY TRUST
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT AND PROTECT
INDIVIDUALS AND COMMUNITIES AT
RISK OF BEING. INAPPROPRIATELY
LABELED AS GANG AFFILIATED. THIS
BILL SHOULD BE THE BEGINNING OF
A LARGER CONVERSATION. WE HAVE
ABOUT THE CAL GAME SYSTEM. BLACK
ANTI LATINO MEN MAKE UP THE
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF
INDIVIDUALS ON THIS DATABASE
AGAIN THERE'S FORTY THOUSAND
INTO OTHER FORTY THOUSAND ISIS
SAY. OUR I SHOULD SAY FORTY
THOUSAND OF THE FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND ON DATABASE ARE BLACK
AND BROWN INDIVIDUALS. IT'S
OUTRAGEOUS TO BELIEVE THAT WITH
THE RAPID GROWTH A WHITE
SUPREMACIST GANGS IN THE UNITED
STATES IN RECENT YEARS ONLY 7%
OF THE TOTAL RECORDS IN THE
DATABASE OR WHITE INDIVIDUALS.
THIS IS CONTINUE TO PERPETUATE
ITSELF THE PRINT PRINT PRINT
PRINT PERPETUATE THE MYTH
DOCTORS SAY THAT ONLY BLACK
LATINO AND ASIAN PEOPLE ARE GANG
MEMBERS. WHEN IN REALITY WHITE
SUPREMACIST GANGS AROUND BUT AS
WELL I HAVE RECENTLY BEEN MADE
AWARE OF LAW ENFORCEMENT'S
CONCERNS WITH THIS MEASURE AND
I'M WILLING TO WORK WITH THEM TO
ADDRESS THESE MINOR CONCERNS. AS
IS MY MAJOR MOVES FORWARD AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO ANYONE
WANTING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
DUE TO CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE CHAIRS MY
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY EACH SIDE WILL HAVE.
BE PERMITTED AN EQUAL AMOUNT OF
TIME TO BE DETERMINED BY THE
CHAIR WHICH I THINK IS JUST TWO
MINUTES- PER EACH SIDE ALL
OTHERS WISHING TO TESTIFY. MUST
LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITIONS
ON THE MEASURES ONLY I WILL NOW
CALL UPON ANY IDENTIFIED
WITNESSES FIRST- IF YOU ARE
PRESENT IN THE HEARING ROOM
SEEING NONE. WE WILL MOVE
REMOTELY- TO THE PHONE. BECAUSE
WE ALSO DON'T HAVE ANYONE IN THE
- WAITING ROOM IN THE OTHER
ROOM- SO NOW MODERATOR IF THERE
IS ANYONE ON THE PHONE WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE TO FIVE. MODERATOR WOULD
YOU PLEASE FROM THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
SB THREE TO FIVE. ANALYSTS JOHN
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF THAT
THE THREE TO FIVE THAT'S ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. OPERATOR
WE'LL FIND YOU A NUMBER. NOW BY
THAT NUMBER. OKAY IF YOU AREN'T
SUPPORT OF F. B. THREE TWO FIVE.
ONE ZERO. ENSURE THIS TIME WE DO
HAVE TO IN OUR QUEUE. OKAY THANK
YOU. START WITH LINE NUMBERS
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI BARBARA
GEORGE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS OF
PH AND RIGHT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. NEXT IS NUMBER
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. PLEASE
HOLD WHILE HOUSTON ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. MR MURRAY SAID THERE ARE
ONLY TWO ARE THERE ANY OTHERS.
AT THE TIME WE HAVE NO OTHERS IN
OUR QUEUE OKAY GREAT NOW WE WILL
MOVE ON TO- THOSE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. OF THE BILL SEEING
NO ONE. IN CONFERENCE ROOM FOR
TWO ZERO THREE I DON'T KNOW IF
WE STILL HAVE THE ROOM SOMEPLACE
OUTSIDE NO WE DON'T HAVE THAT MR
MODERATOR I'M NOW GOING TO GO TO
YOU AND THE PHONE LINES DO YOU
HAVE ANY PEOPLE IN THE QUEUE
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO THE SP THREE TO FIVE YEARS
PLEASE LET ME KNOW AND LET ME
KNOW THE NUMBER. AND IF YOU'RE
IN OPPOSITION TO SB THREE TO
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
. BUT WE DO HAVE ONE IN OUR
QUEUE OKAY THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR PLEASE PROCEED. WE'LL
GO TO NUMBER TWENTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BLACK MAN CHAT ROOMS
RANGE FROM YOU HAVE. WE RESPECT
SHERIFF DECEMBER. THE PARKING
AREA OF BURBANK. OVER THIRTY
HALL I'M SORRY MR MODERATOR
COULD YOU ASK THIS WITNESS TO
EITHER GET CLOSER TO THE PHONE
OR THE MICROPHONE IT IS VERY
HARD TO HEAR HIM. BUT LOOK AT
THE BETTER. THAT'S BETTER IT'S A
LITTLE FUZZY BUT IF WE CAN HEAR
YOU NOW. I HAVE SEVEN DIFFERENT
SETTLEMENT WITH REPRESENTS
PERHAPS BUT IN FACT. SEEN SOME
OF THEM. THANK CORPORATE. THE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM WITH THAT.
AT. TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY FIVE.
I'M SORRY MR IT'S- REALLY
GARBLED AND SO I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU'RE CLOSE TO TWO DEVICES-
IT'S DEFINITELY LOUDER BUT IT'S-
THE RECEPTION HAS GOTTEN WORSE
SO I DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S ANY
KIND OF ADJUSTMENT YOU CAN MAKE
. WE WANT TO TRY TO GET A VITAL
PART OF. AND NO NOW YOU SOUND
LIKE YOU'RE UNDER WATER. THANK
I'LL ADMIT THE BENEFITS A LITTLE
- AND THAT THAT QUESTIONS THAT
WOULD HAPPEN TO THEM- ALL I
HEARD WAS YOU'RE GOING TO SUBMIT
YOUR LETTER TO THE COMMITTEE. I
HAVE. THAT'S RECEIVED. AND THAT
AND PART OF THAT THAT IS FOR THE
RECORD FROM YOUR OFFICE. OKAY
THANK YOU SIR I APOLOGIZE FOR
NOT BEING ABLE TO HEAR YOU BUT
WE WILL NOT YOUR OPPOSITION. SO
ON AND I THINK IT'S A MODERATOR
IS OR ANYONE ELSE ON THE PHONE
LINES. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION. OKAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU TO
ALL OF THOSE WITNESSES WHO
CALLED IN AND SUPPORT AND IN
OPPOSITION. WE WILL NOW BRING
THE DISCUSSION BACK TO THE
MEMBERS. DO ANY OF OUR MEMBERS
HAVE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SENATOR SKINNER. THANK YOU CHAIR
THANK YOU- CENTER RADFORD FOR
BRINGING THE BILL- WHEN I LOOK
AT THE DATA. NOW SERVING ON THE
PENAL CODE REVIEW COMMITTEE AND
I LOOK AT THE DATA OF HOW MANY-
INDIVIDUALS RECEIVE THE- GETTING
ADVANCEMENT AND IN ADDITION TO
THAT HOW MANY INDIVIDUALS
SERVING TIME HAVE- BEEN. WRITTEN
UP FOR TOO LATE EITHER DELAY FOR
PAROLE FOR UNFAIRLY CONSIDERED
CONTROL BECAUSE OF. OF THE
INDICATION THAT THEY HAVE A GANG
AFFILIATION WITH AND WITHOUT.
WITH WHAT. IS I MEAN WHAT. DOES
THE BEST- IN A COURT WOULD FAR
WOULD NEED MUCH MORE
DOCUMENTATION AND SUBSTANTIATION
OR IN NORMAL LIFE YOU KNOW HAVE
TO CHOOSE A CERTAIN EFFECT
THAT'S- SO I THINK WHAT YOU ARE-
HI. I WOULD LOVE TO BE ABLE TO
EVEN GO FURTHER AND I KNOW I'M
SURE YOU WOULD TOO BUT I THINK.
YOUR APPROACH IS THE RIGHT WAY
TO YOU KNOW MAKE SOME PROGRESS
ON THIS. AND AS WE FIGURE OUT
WHAT MORE- BUT I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING WITH
THAT'LL MOVE IT. THANK YOU
SENATOR SKINNER. ANY OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE SENATOR OTOBO I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENTS BECAUSE YOU'RE- DOING
IT. THROUGH TELECONFERENCE-
THANK YOU I. WONDER I JUST MET
QUESTION I'M I'M NEW TO THE-
THIS CALL MAYBE I UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE'S AT LEAST ON OUR
SIDE THERE'S BEEN CONCERNS I'M
ON MY SIDE YOU NEED. EVERY
SEASON CONCERNS FOR MY DISTRICT
WITH REGARDS TO DISPEL AND HOW
THAT IT COMPROMISES OUT OF ETL
PRIOR- AND- HIGHER BAIL OUT
FROM. US AS SOMEONE NUMBER THEN
SOMEONE NUMBER WHATEVER WHAT ARE
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT. ARE YOUR
COMMENTS ON THAT.I AM
UNFAMILIAR WITH THAT COMPROMISE
BUT ARE WELL AWARE OF THE BILL
THAT DR WEBBER. HAS DONE AND I
THINK THIS ONLY ENHANCES WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVE AND
MAKING SURE THAT INDIVIDUALS ARE
NOT. A WRONGLY PLACED ON GANG
DATABASES SO I DON'T THINK THERE
IS A CONFLICT IN WHICH- WITH
ACTION TODAY- THAT WHICH- NOW
SECRETARY OF STATE WEBER
AUTHORIZED A FEW YEARS AGO.
SENATE AVAILABLE DID YOU HAVE A
FOLLOW UP. THAT'S IT THANK YOU
YOU. I'M A SINNER BRADFORD I
JUST ALSO WANT TO THANK YOU FOR-
RAINING AND THEY'RE STILL FOR
YOU KNOW I WORKED ON AB THREE
THREE THREE AND THE ISSUE AROUND
GANG DATABASES ARE VERY
IMPORTANT TO ME AND I THINK
ACTUALLY ADDING THIS KIND OF
MEMBER. TO THE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THOSE THAT
HAVE EXPERIENCE- NOT JUST
PROSECUTING THAT SORT OF WORKING
ON THE DEFENDANT AND DUE PROCESS
SIDE. HAVE A LOT OF EXPERTISE IN
THE FIELD OF. HOW WHO AND HOW
OFTEN PEOPLE ARE PLACED ON THE
DATABASE WHAT KIND OF CRITERIA
IS USED WHAT KIND OF
SUBJECTIVITY IS USED. WITH
REGARD TO THAT KIND OF CRITERIA
AND IT COULD POTENTIALLY. OPEN
UP- DISCUSSIONS TO BE A LITTLE
MORE TRANSPARENT A LITTLE MORE
REFLECTIVE A LITTLE MORE HONEST-
AND SOBERING WITH REGARDS TO HOW
THE K. GAL. HOW GETTING DATABASE
IS USED- AND ENFORCED YOU KNOW
COUNTY BY COUNTY ACROSS THE
STATE AND FEDERAL. AND AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME I WOULD
ACTUALLY LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A
CO AUTHOR. THANK YOU FOR THE
WINNER THANK YOU FOR JOINING US
WE ARE CURRENTLY ON F. B. THREE
TO FIVE BRADFORD- THE CRIMINAL
GANG SHARED GANG DATABASE DO YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FOR THE
AUTHOR AT THIS TIME. NO THANK
YOU OKAY SENATOR BRADFORD THERE
ARE NO OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU MA'AM CHEERING
THANK YOU MEMBERS I THINK THIS
IS A STREET FOR MEASURE AS IT
STATES WE JUST SIMPLY WANT TO
ADD SOMEONE. WHO BRINGS A WEALTH
OF EXPERIENCE AND HELPING TO
DISCERN AND- MAKE A CORRECT
IDENTIFICATIONS OF INDIVIDUALS
WHO SHOULD. OR SHOULD NOT BE
PLACED ON THE GAME- CAL. GANG
DATABASE AS WE WELL KNOW R. AS
C. TWO SIX ARE SHOWN AS IN DOUBT
AS SHOWN. YOU HAVE KIDS SIMPLY
LIVING IN THE WRONG NEIGHBORHOOD
WHO HAVE BEEN PUT ON GAME DAY
GRUB DATABASES YOU HAVE. SENIORS
WHO HAVE BEEN STOPPED SIMPLY
BECAUSE THEY LIVE IN A GANG
INFESTED NEIGHBORHOOD AND THEY
TOO HAVE BEEN PUT ON A GAME
DATABASE AND I THINK THIS MAKES
ABSOLUTELY NO SENSE WE- KNOW
THE- LONG- RAIN IMPACTS OF BEING
ON THIS. DATABASE IS OUT FROM
AFFECTING EMPLOYMENT TO- HOUSING
AND ON AND ON AND ON SO- I THINK
ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO HELP
STRENGTHEN THEM AND MAKE SURE
THAT- IT'S- REAL TRANSPARENCY
AND POP ON THIS AS TO WE- AS
MOVING FORWARD THIS DATABASE
WILL ONLY. AID IN. ACCOMPLISHING
OUR GOALS SO WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
PHONE. THANK YOU SENATOR
BRADFORD THE BILL HAD BEEN MOVED
BY SENATOR SCANNER- THERE'S AN
IRAQ GO FROM THE CHAIR. THIS THE
ROLL VOTE. MOTION IS GIVE SB
TWENTY FIVE BRADFORD. I THE
TROUBLED PROPERLY ABOUT NOT
VOTING FROM LAGER HI I'M
MARGARET I CAN- I CAN R. I.
WINNER. WINNER I BUILD FORTY
ZERO THANK YOU THAT BILL IS OUT
OF FOUR I WAS WITH ONE
ABSTENTION. NOW WE WILL MOVE ON
TO THE NEXT TIME I WILL TURN TO
GO BACK TO THE CHAIR. LET'S
QUICKLY MOVED TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR PLEASE WE HAVE ONE ITEM
ON CONSENT. THAT'S S. B. FOUR
SIX SEVEN CAN WE GET A MOTION ON
THE CONSENT ITEMS. HE'S BEEN
MOVED BY SENATORS. AKAM LONGER-
MA'AM CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON S. V. FOUR SIX SEVEN
CONSENT ITEMS. AS REPORTED SEVEN
CONSENT BRADFORD OUR RECORD I A
TURBO. I OKAY I COM LARGER HI I.
SCANNER SCANNER I WINNER WINNER
I'D FIVE ZERO. THAT MEASURES OUT
FIVE ZERO THANK YOU NOW I SEE WE
HAVE SENATOR BATES PRESIDENT SHE
HAS S. P. SEVEN FIVE SEVENTY
FIVE SO SENATOR BATES WHEN
YOU'RE READY YOU MAY BEGIN. WELL
THANK YOU- MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF I'M HERE TO PRESENT
SB SEVENTY FIVE AND I KNOW THAT
YOU'VE ALL HEARD FROM ME FOR HER
ON THIS ONE I READ THE ISSUE
FORWARD AGAIN TO THE SENATE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE OF FAT
NO HOUSE ARE REALLY ARE
SKYROCKETED IN TERMS OF- HITS
OUR DRUG OF PREFERENCE FOR
IMPORTATION DISTRIBUTION BY THE
CARTELS- IT OUT YES B. R.
SEVENTY FIVE ADDS THAT NOW TO
THE LIST OF DANGEROUS DRUGS
INCLUDING HEROIN AND COCAINE.
WHICH ARE SUBJECT TO SENTENCE
ENHANCEMENTS THAT ARE BASED ON
WEIGHT IT IS UP TO FIFTY TIMES
MORE POTENT THAN PHARMACEUTICAL
GRADE HEROIN IS OFTEN MIXED WITH
HEROIN AND OTHER DRUGS WITHOUT
THE KNOWLEDGE OF USERS HOWEVER
IT IS NOW BEING IMPORTED UNITS
UP YOUR FIRM FORM BECAUSE OF
FENTANYL'S POTENCY OVERDOSES ARE
MORE LIKELY TO BE FATAL IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT FAT NAIL
CAN BE DEADLY SIMPLY IF IT
BECOMES AIRBORNE OR MAKES
CONTACT WITH SKIN POSING
SIGNIFICANT DANGER. TO FIRST
RESPONDERS AS SHOWN IN THE GRAPH
THAT I HOPE YOU ALL HAVE A VIEW
OF NOW WE'VE PROVIDED YOU- THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
ESTIMATES THAT FENTANYL RELATED
DEATHS SKYROCKETED BY OVER 1000%
STATEWIDE BETWEEN TWENTY SIXTEEN
AND TWENTY TWENTY MORE
SPECIFICALLY THE OVERDOSES ROSE
FROM TWO HUNDRED AND ONE IN
262-300-0900 AND FORTY SIX AND
pFIFTIETH THE KIDS THINK SPEAK
VOLUMES TO THE NEED FOR THE BILL
IT CRACKS DOWN ON DRUG CARTELS
AND HIGH LEVEL DRUG DEALERS THAT
ARE DISTRIBUTING TRAFFICKING AND
SELLING MASS QUANTITIES OF THIS
POISON THE BILL WOULD ONLY GO
INTO EFFECT SOMEONE IS CAUGHT
WITH IT. MORE MORE THE KILOGRAM
OF FENTANYL HELD A STREET VALUE
OF ANYWHERE FROM ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO SEVERAL
MILLION IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT POSITION OF THIS AMOUNT IS
SOMEWHAT RARE WHEN I FIRST
INTRODUCEDTHE BILL IN. TWENTY
SIXTEEN IT WAS. I BELIEVE THE
MOST SELLERS COULD CAUSE. MY AS
LIKE. OF INCLUDING MANY HIGH.
LEVEL DEALER HOWEVER THERE HAS A
THIRD INCREASE. IN C. OF. THAT
EXCEED ONE KILOGRAM. AND JUST
THE PAST FOUR WEEKS. THE ORANGE
COUNTY SHERIFF SEE THE KILO OF
FENTANYL WE NEED TO SEND A
pIS EVEN WORSE. SB SEVENTY FIVE
COULD REDUCE FUTURE TRAFFICKING
LEVEL. THE BILL DOES NOT CHANGE
SENTENCES FOR END USERS ARE FOR
THOSE USING MEDICAL FAT NOW FOR
ITS LEGITIMATE AND PRESCRIBED
PURPOSE. THE BILL GIVES LAW
ENFORCEMENT THEY NEEDED TOOL TO
PREVENT AN EPIDEMIC. OF DEATHS
AND OVERDOSES HAPPENING
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE. FIVE TWO
WITNESSES WITH ME TODAY. THE
FIRST OF MARCH COUNTY SHRIFF
DON BAR. HE WILL STAY ON THE
LINE TO HELP ANSWER QUESTIONS IF
NEEDED AND SECONDLY IF THE MEDIA
WILL. BE CONSTITUENT FROM MY
DISTRICT. YOU'RE FAR TOO PREMIER
WITNESSES ARE PREPARED WE WILL
PROVIDE YOU TWO MINUTES EACH SO-
WE'LL START WITH THE SHERIFF
PLEASE BEAR. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN I MET AND AFTER THIS
COMMITTEE ONCE AGAIN TO HELP
ADDRESS. WITH THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC SAFETY HEALTH
CRISIS OF OUR TIME FENTANYL.
THIS BILL COME BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE SEVERAL TIMES THAT'S
BEEN REPEATEDLY REJECTED.
CONSEQUENTLY AS EACH YEAR PASSES
MORE PEOPLE DIE IN THE
PROLIFERATION OF FENTANYL GROWS
. WHEN I SPOKE ALOUD TO THIS
COMMITTEE IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN TO SENATOR SPECIFICALLY
STATED ONE THE PEOPLE ARE NOT
DYING AT A DISPROPORTIONATE RATE
COMPARED TO OTHER DRUGS. AND TO
THAT FENTANYL IS ALWAYS MIXED
WITH OTHER DRUGS MAKING THIS
LEGISLATION UNNECESSARY. WITH
THESE TWO STATEMENTS THE MIND
LET'S LOOK AT OUR MOST RECENT
DATA. IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
THE NUMBER STATEWIDE FENTANYL
DEATHS WITH SEVEN HUNDRED EIGHTY
SIX. IN TWENTY TWENTY DEATHS
ROSE 230-009-0040 SIX. A 4100%
INCREASE THAT'S ON PACE TO
DOUBLE AGAIN IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. SENATOR WINNER DURING THE
SAME THREE APPARENT FENTANYL
DEATHS IN SAN FRANCISCO
INCREASED FOURTEEN FIFTY
PERCENT. SENATOR BRADFORD IN
CALM WATER. SAMPLES INCREASED
THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO
PERCENT. SENATOR JOE ABOUT
SABATINO INCREASED SIX HUNDRED
FIFTY SIX PERCENT. AND SENATOR
SKINNER ALAMEDA COUNTY SON
ALARMING INCREASE OF. 710035%
AND DENTAL RELATED DEATHS.
REGARDING THE SECOND THAT
SENTINELS ALWAYS MIXED WITH
OTHER DRUGS MY DEPARTMENT ALONE
HAS SEIZED NEARLY FOUR HUNDRED
POUNDS OF PURE FENTANYL OVER THE
PAST FIVE YEARS. IN FACT THE
FAILURE OF THIS COMMITTEE TO
RECOGNIZE THE LEGITIMATE RAFT
CALIFORNIA. HAS CREATED A
PERVERSE INCENTIVE ENCOURAGING
DRUG CARTELS TO TRAFFIC
BUREAUCRAT TO NOW. THAT THE
CONSEQUENCESFOR DOING SO ARE
LESS THAN TRAFFICKING ARGUABLY
LESS DANGEROUS NARCOTICS. THE
SENATE WHAT THE SOLUTION IS
SIMPLE. RECTOR THE DISPARITY IN
SENTENCING LAWS. DOESN'T MAKE
CLEAR THAT THOSE PROFITING FROM
THE LIVES OF OTHERS WILL BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE IN THE SAME MANNER
FOR TRAFFICKING OTHER DANGEROUS
NARCOTICS. YOU CAN NO LONGER
IGNORE OR EXPLAIN AWAY THE REST
YOUR CONSTITUENTS. THE SUPPORT
COMMONSENSE LEGISLATION THAT
WILL PROTECT THE RESIDENTS OF
CALIFORNIA VOTE YES ON SB.
SEVENTY FIVE THE LIVES OF SO
MANY PEOPLE DEPEND UPON IT.
THANK YOU THERE TO WITNESS. AND
SUPPORT. HI MY NAME IS AND I AM
FROM ORANGE COUNTY CALIFORNIA I
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME TODAY
AND FOR YOUR EFFORTS IN HELPING
THOSE SUFFERING FROM ADDICTION
AND SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER. BUT
THESE EFFORTS EXTENDED BEYOND
THE REFLECTION. CATEGORY OF A
YOUNGER MORE INNOCENT VICTIMS IN
FRONT OF THE RUSSIAN COMMUNITY
THAN AN ENTIRE GENERATION OF NEW
CONTENT REALIZE WHAT'S HAPPENING
. AND THAT THIS. AT THE TOP OF
MY MIND. TWENTY FOURTEEN YEAR
OLD THAT. BUT VERY MUCH WE
DROPPED FROM THE NIGHT BEFORE MY
- I WOULD DIE DURING THE NIGHT
AFTER TAKING A- LOOK HELLO.
PHOTO ID WITH DATE OF BIRTH AND
NOW A SINGLE CAT SINGLE
COUNTERFEIT HUNG OUT THAT ALONE
IN THE BEDROOM THAT START WITH
THE TRUCK BY TEN O'CLOCK. THAT
NIGHT. THEY PLAYED. AT THE
PRESENT EVER INCREASE CATEGORY
OF THE IN THE TRUCK. RIGHT THANK
YOU FOR HANDLING. SEVENTEEN BUT
MANY KIDS THAT THEY- ADDITIONAL
. YOU WITH EVER SO WITH DRUGS
BECAUSE WAS AT FOURTEEN I DON'T
ONLY AND I'M WILLING BECAME UP
WITH THAT OF GENERATION. I'M NOT
GOING BACK TO THE COMMUNITIES
CHANGE THE GAME EFFECTIVE POWER
. BECOME THAT AT ANY WITH THAT
DRUG PREVIOUSLY IT. BY. PEOPLE
ARE FROM THE- AFTER TAKING WHAT
THEY BELIEVE. THOUSANDS OF
OTHERS RIGHT WE KNOW THAT IF
THEY ARE NOT IT'S NOT MORE THAN
A FEW THINGS ABOUT ABOUT THREE
TO FIVE MILLIGRAM. THE DRUG.
FINALLY THE PROSPECT REPLACEMENT
. HOW TO CHANGE THE PROGRAM
EIGHT AND RECOGNIZING THE FACT
THAT THE FIRST MEETING WITH. THE
FOR MEDICAL USE IT HAS A HIGH-
BEING. WELL DONE AT AN ALARMING
RATE. F. SEVENTY FIVE PROVIDE
APPROPRIATE BUT- THOSE
PROCESSING LARGE QUANTITIES FOR
THE PURPOSE OF WHICH- I HAVE AN
AFFINITY FOR FURTHER LEGISLATIVE
DEBATE. BUT I'M- THAT'S YOUR
MONEY THE MANAGER BUT DEFINITELY
THE LEGISLATION YOUR COMMENT
THAT THAT PERHAPS. HE PUT ON
FILE LAST MINUTE- I COULDN'T
AGREE MORE HI THOUSANDS OF OTHER
FAMILIES WITH ROCK AND
IMMEDIATE. BYLAWS RELATING TO
THE. TRAGIC NORTH PATTON. THANK
YOU COMPETITION AROUND THREE AND
THAT. ABOUT TEN AND- PROPERLY
THANK YOU FOR WAITING TO RIGHT
CLICK ON THAT ENTRY NUMBER. HOW
MUCH CONFIGURATION OF. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY NOW WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE HEARING
FORTY TWO- THREE I SEE THE
VERSION WITNESS HERE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT NOW WE'LL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES MR MODERATOR OR
OTHER INDIVIDUALS IN Q. WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVENTY FIVE. IN LATE JUDGMENTS
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THAT SEVENTY
FIVE. ZERO AT THE TIME. AGAIN
ONE ZERO DURING THE COURSE OF
THAT FIVE. AND AT THIS TIME THAT
WE GIVE ABOUT FIFTY. MODERATOR
WE CAN BARELY HEAR YOU- AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE ABOUT FIFTEEN IN
OUR QUEUE. OKAY WELL LET'S BEGIN
AGAIN WE'RE GIVING OUR NAME AND
OUR POSITION AND THIS IS-
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. WE'LL START WITH LINE THIRTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND THEN
A THIRD SHOT LECTURE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION IF THE PART OF AN
ADULT SEVENTY FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THE QUICKNESS. NEXT TO
BE NUMBER FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD
. GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS BRIAN SHERMAN
REPRESENTING THE RIVERSIDE
CHURCH YOU CAN'T HAVE A POLICE
OFFICER YOU CAN. OKAY DON'T
WORRY YOU WON'T BE DAY WILL WORK
ARCADIA BUT- TEN AND POSTED IT
OR- BY. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
WE GOT A LINE THIRTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ROUNDED UP ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY FAIR. NEXT NEXT
WITNESS. A LINE TWENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WE'LL GO TO LINE TWENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS EDWIN
PERFORMED ON BEHALF OF. WE
PROVIDE FOR. THE NEXT WITNESS.
NEXT IS NUMBER TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF RIGHT- HE WAS FIFTEEN
YEARS OLD. WHEN HE WAS- WHAT HE
BELIEVED TO BE HISPANIC. ON
TWITTER AND IT ACTUALLY TURNED
OUT TO BE NO- PLEASE. WAIT A
YEAR- THE NUMBER OF PORTS. RIGHT. YOU NEXT WITNESS. NEXT TO BE
NUMBER THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBER OF THE SHOP FOR REPAIRS.
YEAH AND BOTH THE PEOPLE THIRTY
THREE THIRTY THIRTY THE
CALIFORNIA AND THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY FIFTY TEN HIGHWAY
PATROLMAN I. THE NEXT WITNESS.
FINE THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS MAX WITHOUT
CALLING ON BEHALF OF MY DAUGHTER
OUT AND RECAP THOUGH KILLED BY A
DRUG DEALER THE OLDER COUNTY
THAT HE COULDN'T TELL ME THAT
THAT'S NOT. IN LINE WITH THE
PART OF THE- THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT IS NUMBER THIRTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
JEREMY SANDERSON I'M CALLING.
BECAUSE MY SON TYLER DIED FROM
PURE BUT NOT ALL. THE IMPORT OF
THE. THANK YOU THANK GOODNESS.
NEXT IS NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME'S STEVE BEGAY
TERRACE AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF MY GODSEND DANIEL
ALLEGED FIGUEROA WHO WAS PRESENT
BY FAITH NO LAST YEAR. AND I
SUPPORT BILL I SUPPORT THIS BILL
SPC. THANK YOU. FINE. THIRTY
EIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
BRAD BIRD THE FIRST PHONE CALL
IN BEHALF OF FORTY PLEASE KEEP
THE CIRCULATION IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. THANK YOU THANKS TO
THIS PLACE. NEXT IN LINE THIRTY
ONE. HI MY NAME IS ERICA AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF MY SON
DANIEL FIGUEROA WELL THE REASON
BY FRANCE AND I HAVE THAT HERE I
AM IN FOR THE BEST B. SEVENTY
FIVE. THANK YOU NOTES WITH. NEXT
IS NUMBER TWENTY FIVE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS KIND OF
WHAT THE PRESIDENT OF VICTIMS OF
THE DRUG BOY AND WE SUPPORT AT
LEAST SEVENTY FIVE. THANK YOU
WOULDN'T. NEXT IS NUMBER THIRTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HM NUMBER
MY NAME IS RED CLICK HERE AND I
AM REPRESENTING MY FRIEND BACK
THREE THIRTY- EXCELLENT POINT
AND I HAVE NOT IT KIND OF
COOKING HER IN THE COUNTY AND
YOUR ACCOUNT- I STRONGLY THE
POINT IS THAT. RIGHT YEAH. WILL
NOW GO TO NUMBER ELEVEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JILL THAT
IS CORRECT I AM CALLING ON
BEHALF OF ALEXANDER LEVEL AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU
NEXT WOULDN'T. I WILL NOT GO TO
NUMBER FORTY TWO. HM MEMBERS
CATAMARAN WITH A HAND WRITTEN
ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING THE
ORANGE COUNTY PRODUCTS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT THE BILL
THANK YOU. YOU WOULDN'T. NEXT IS
NUMBER FORTY ONE. FIVE THE
FAMILY OF COURSE. I AM HERE ON
BEHALF OF MY FRIENDS BUT BOTH.
ONE OF BECAUSE I HAVE A ROOM
THIRTY BUT WHEN I ACTUALLY FOUND
OUT THAT HER FRIEND. MA'AM AT
NUMBER. READ THAT THE- NUMBER
HONEY TRY- AND CRIMINAL YOUR
NAME YOUR POSITION PLEASE THANK
YOU. BY MANAGEMENT FAMILY OF
FOUR AT THE END OF THE MONTH AT
THE FIFTH BUT- WITH AN- WITH.
WITH THE FIVE PEOPLE TO RUN
THINGS LET. THAT'S NOT
RECOGNIZED BY THE COURT RIGHT
NOW MY HAND HI THAT IS NOT
RECOGNIZED. ABSOLUTELY A HUNDRED
AT I MET THAT AFTER. I AM
DEFINITELY IN SUPPORT OF THAT
FIVE THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
NEXT IS NUMBER TWENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NUMBER TWENTY PLEASE MAKE
SURE IT'S NOT A NEW. AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE NO OTHERS IN OUR
QUEUE. OKAY THANK YOU NOW WE'LL
GO TO WITNESSES AND OPPOSITION.
WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES HERE IN
THE CHAMBER AND OPPOSITION TO SB
SEVEN FIVE. CENA NAINA EACH
MODERATOR OR OTHER WITNESSES IN
Q. WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB SEVENTY FIVE.
JOHN IF YOU ARE IN A POSITION AT
THE SEVEN FIVE PRESS ONE ZERO.
THE PROPOSITION WOULD PRESS ONE
ZERO. AT THE TIME WE DO WAKE MR
MODERATOR MIGHT MY MISTAKE WE DO
HAVE LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES
I'M SORRY I MISSED THEM- WE HAVE
GENET SANTA PAT PATTON. AND WE
HAVE GLENN BACKUS. SO IS GENET
READY THE DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE.
I'M TAKING A LOOK YES WE CAN
HEAR YOU WILL PROVIDE YOU TWO
MINUTES AND THEN WE'LL GIVE
MISTER BACCHUS TWO MINUTES AS
WELL. RIGHT I'M GOOD AFTERNOON
CABINET MEMBERS MY NAME IS TO
THAT BUT BEING THAT I HAVE ONE
ON THE LINE. WE HAVE AN
ORGANIZATION- ADVOCATING FOR
EXTRA POLICIES BY THE FAITH
COMPASSION. RIGHT I AM HERE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION AT SEVEN I
THE TRUTH INCREASED. PENALTIES
FOR THE FOR OUR PROFESSION. THE
PEOPLE LIVE THE PAPERS WERE NOT
THERE TO LOOK AT THE OTHER LIKE
THAT NOW. OR THE BANK. UNDER MY
CURRENT TO ADDRESS THE- OVERDOSE
CRISIS BY TRIBAL PEOPLE WHO'VE
MOVED BACK AWAY FROM HELP THAT
IS CORRECT AND THEN KIND OF
DRIFT INTO THAT. WITH COVER
PROTECTION AND. SPECIAL EVENTS
SO THAT COMES UP WITH THE AND
THE FACT. I FINE WITH THAT WITH
THAT THE NAFTA. CONSISTENT WITH
THE PROVIDED BY A LOT CALIFORNIA. BUT AFTER THAT ALL OVER THE
AFTER THE FIRST TEN MONTHS WITH
MY. NINETY THREE OVER THE RIGHT
AT THE KREMLIN MATTER THE PUBLIC
HEALTH MATTERS IT WAS JUST
DOCTORS AT NORTH REED CUT IS
THAT THE PROBLEM. TRANSACTION
FOR COMPREHENSIVE MOVIE AND THEN
I HAVE A ACT. THAT. PROFESSIONAL
ATHLETES AND- RIGHT TO. AT THE
BASED SOLUTIONS AND PROVIDE
TREATMENT AND HAVE A CAN IT BUT
LIKE WITH. THANK YOU FROM FEDEX
YOU FOR THAT OVER THE BIT OF
ECHO THEY ARE THE ONES THAT.
THANK YOU FOR THAT BUT THAT. BUT
THE HI I'VE BEEN ON THE BOOKS
PROTECTED. YEAH NO AND RIGHT
AFTER THE RIGHT SO THE PENALTY.
WE CANNOT CONTINUE TO CLICK
THROUGH AND WHEN OPEN THANK AT
THAT TIME THE THANK. THE VERSION
THAT OF THE- ROUND WITH AT.
THANK YOU FOR. THANK YOU RETAIL
NOW WE'RE GOING TO CLAIM BACK AS. THIS MODERATORS ARE SECOND
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION. AVAILABLE. IF YOU SHOW MR OUT CONNECTED-
PLEASE MAKE SURE NONE OF YOU.
DO
WE HAVE MISTER PACKAGES
AVAILABLE. DO YOU SHOVE- BACK IT
IS CONNECTED.
IF YOU WANTED TO
GO TO OTHER WITNESSES ON THE
PHONE LINE AN OPPOSITION. MR
MODERATOR DO YOU HAVE CALLERS IN
Q. WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO S. P. SEVENTY FIVE
. AGAIN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION TO THE SP
SEVEN FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
. HELLO. I FORGOT TO. WHEN. YES
THIS IS GOING BACK UP DON'T TAKE
A STEP IN THE RIGHT BACK I'VE
BEEN ABLE TO HEAR YOU. OKAY WE
CAN BARELY HEAR YOU SERVE YOU
CAN SPEAK UP I THINK IT'S ALL
OVER ALL BACK IN ACTION TODAY
BUT WE'LL DO OUR BEST. I
APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. BUT THIRTEEN FIFTY SEVEN
ALL AMERICAN BACK UPON HIM.
RIGHT. DON'T WASTE THE PEOPLE'S
MONEY. IF THAT HAPPENS BUT NOW
ABOUT WE'RE PLANNING COMPANY
METHAMPHETAMINES DECADES. AND
THAT SIX ZERO. SEVEN APPROACH
DID NOT REDUCE AVAILABILITY OF.
OKAY METHAMPHETAMINE. FIVE THE
COMMITTEE COULD NOT THE MISTAKES
OF PAST. SECOND CONGRATULATIONS
TO THE EXPENSIVE PART NETWORK'S
BEEN FIFTY OFF BUT BUT- IT COULD
SEND MORE EXPENSE THAT
PERFORMANCE THE PAYMENT AND MUCH
MORE EXPENSIVE THAN COUNTRY. HOW
BEEN APPROVED APPROVING TO
RECONSTRUCT THE FOR TRUCKS BY
OVER THE- RECORDING TO FIND
RIGHT YEAH. EVERY PRESIDENT
COUGH THE- AROUND A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS THE.
ACCORDING TO CUT USE A METHOD OF
TREATMENT. SIX OUT SIX HUNDRED
PER YEAR. I THOUGHT IT WOULD
WORKING. SIX THOUSAND PER YEAR.%
WHAT MORE SENSE IN TERMS HELPING
THINGS THE FED SEVENTY PEOPLE
AFRICA I THANK YOU FOR NOT
ADVERTISEMENT RUN. YEAH. BUT NO
ONE COULD. THE PEOPLE PRISON FOR
THE FINAL TWENTY YEARS I DON'T
THINK BUT CONDUCT. THAT'S WHAT
THE RESEARCH SHOWS. HOWEVER OVER
FIVE BALANCE OF PAYMENTS WITH
THEM AS WELL IF PRODUCTS IS MORE
INTELLIGENT. NOT CONNECTED WITH
IT. IN F. B. SEVENTY FIVE
REAFFIRMED MUCH. RESERVED FOR
THAT WORK. I RESPECT THAT- BUT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NUMBER
MODERATOR WILL MOVE BACK TO OUR
PHONE LINES AND SEE IF THERE IN
KEY WHICH TO TESTIFY AND TO AS
SEVEN FIVE. BUT WE DO HAVE FOR
IN OUR QUEUE AND OPPOSITION. BUT
WE WILL START WITH NUMBER THIRTY
FIVE WE'VE GOT. GOOD AFTERNOON-
KATHY SHONDA HALF OF WHAT I LOVE
CALIFORNIA ACTION IN. THANK YOU
NEED TO ADDRESS. NEXT TO THE
NUMBER SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE CARD FROM HOUSTON FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANKS TO
NUMBER FORTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU FOR CALLING IN
PART TODAY CAN WE GET THAT PART
RIGHT- BUT I'M CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE ORANGE COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE. THE STAFF.
THANK YOU MY GOODNESS. THE NEXT
NUMBER. GO AHEAD. DANIEL AFTER
THE CALL THE PROJECTED IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. AT THIS TIME THERE ARE
NO OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE YEAH OKAY
WE'RE GONNA BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR DISCUSSION ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS-
IN REGARDS TO THIS MERGER BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. IN CENTER
WHERE. I THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
AND I WANNA I EVEN THOUGH WE
WERE A DISAGREEMENT HERE I DO
WANT A THANK- THE SENATOR FROM
THERE WE'RE GOING TO GO FOR
FOCUSING ON THE DISASTER THAT
IS- FUNCTIONAL AND EVEN FOCUSING
ON FOR A LONG TIME. AND EVEN
THOUGH YOU AND I MAY HAVE
DIFFERENT APPROACHES FROM TIME
TO TIME. I DO REALLY APPRECIATE
AND RESPECT THAT YOU'VE BEEN SO
TENACIOUS. IN TRYING TO ELEVATE
THIS ISSUE. FANS AND ALL IS-
IT'S A PUBLIC HEALTH DISASTER- I
THINK THERE WAS A- COMMENT
EARLIER ABOUT SAN FRANCISCO AND
ABSOLUTELY FUNCTIONAL HAS. BEEN
A SIGNIFICANT- FACTOR IN THE
EXPLOSION OF OVERDOSE. DEATHS IN
SAN FRANCISCO- HEROIN IN MATH
ARE ALSO SIGNIFICANT FACTORS BUT
FUNCTIONAL. HAS SUPER CHARGED
AND I KNOW THAT THAT IS TRUE-
ELSEWHERE- THIS IS- JUST A
HORRIFIC PERNICIOUS- A DRUG THAT
IS- KILLING PEOPLE. AND IF OUR
INCREASING CORPORATION FOR THE
STRONG WERE- OR AN EFFECTIVE
STRATEGY- I THINK HAVING A LOT
OF PEOPLE WOULD BE OPEN TO IT
BUT WE KNOW FROM EXPERIENCE THAT
IT'S NOT. AN EFFECTIVE STRATEGY
AND OF MR BACCHUS POINTED OUT-
WE WERE INCREASING IT HAPPENS
FOR OTHER DRUGS. ARE FOR MANY
YEARS. AND PEOPLE ARE. STILL
DYING FROM THE DRUGS AND EVEN
MORE MORE SO IN THE- AND SO I.
YOU KNOW WE CAN ALL AGREE THAT
THIS IS A TEST AN ABSOLUTE
DISASTER- BUT IT'S- ADDING AN
ADDITIONAL ENHANCEMENT IS NOT
GOING TO- THE TO SOLVE OR
IMPROVE THIS- DISASTER- POLICE
AND DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ALREADY
HAVE TOOLS ON TO ADDRESS THE
SOON TO SEND PEOPLE TO STAY
PRESENT- FOR POSSESSING LARGE
QUANTITIES OF FENTANYL. I DON'T
THINK THAT INCREASING THE LENGTH
OF AN INCARCERATION IS GOING TO-
SOLVE THIS PROBLEM THERE ARE A
LOT OF OTHER THINGS WE SHOULD BE
DOING OR WORKING ON SOME OF
THOSE FROM A PUBLIC HEALTH
PERSPECTIVE I. AM LISTENING TO A
NUMBER OF OTHER STRATEGIES FOR
EXAMPLE THIS YEAR I'M FOCUSED ON
TRYING TO EXPAND ACCESS TO
FENTANYL TESTING STRIPS OF THE
PEOPLE ON THE THESE TERRIBLE
TERRIBLE TRAGEDIES OF PEOPLE
TAKING UP WHAT THEY THINK OF THE
PERCOCET OR OR OR OTHER- HELLO
AND ENDS UP BEING LACED WITH
SOMETHING ON A GUY. WE WANT
PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE INGESTING SO THERE ARE
STRATEGIES THAT I THINK- CAN
HELP- BUT UGH I'M NOT GONNA BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY
THANK YOU. SENATOR SKINNER.
THANK YOU TERROR AND- THANK YOU
SENATOR WIENER FOR YOUR
COMMENTS- SENATOR BATES I SHARE
THE HORROR AT. THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHO HAVE DIED AND THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE DIED ON
KNOWINGLY BECAUSE THEY HAD NO
IDEA THAT THERE WAS FENTANYL IN
THE THING THEY WERE INTERESTING
FOR POTENTIALLY SHOOTING UP. AND
WHILE THERE'S A LEVEL OF RISK.
THAT I CERTAINLY AM NOT WILLING
TO TAKE IN ANY KIND OF INJECTION
DRUG. WE KNOW THAT MANY OF THE
FENTANYL DEATHS ARE DUE TO
PEOPLE TAKING WHAT THEY THINK
ARE PRESCRIPTION DRUGS. THE
BOUGHT ILLEGALLY IN BOUGHT ON
THE BLACK MARKET BUT STILL THEY
THINK THAT THEY ARE RIGHT THEY
ARE GETTING A PRESCRIPTION DRUG.
AND FROM THAT POINT OF VIEW I.
AGREE WITH THOSE FAMILIES TO
DESCRIBE IT IS THESE ARE NOT
OVERDOSE DEATHS. THESE ARE
POISONING THESE ARE AND WHILE.
WHILE THERE IS A USE FOR FAT
KNOWING. SOME LEVEL OF PAIN
TREATMENT. I WOULD I WOULD. I
WOULDN'T TREAT THE MEDICAL
COMMUNITY TO COME UP WITH
ALTERNATIVES THAT WE WOULD NOT
EVEN UTILIZE THAT NO IN A HEALTH
STUDY THAT THERE MUST BE OTHER
WAYS TO CONTROL PAIN BECAUSE OF
THE TOXICITY OF THIS PARTICULAR
SUBSTANCE SO IN AN INTERESTING
WAY I THINK WE SHOULDN'T EVEN BE
DEALING WITH IT IN ANY OF OUR
DRESS CODE. BECAUSE IT'S A IT'S
A POISONOUS A TOXIN NOW
CERTAINLY WHEN SOMEONE OVERDOSES
FROM LIKE A STRICT STRICT DRUG
NOT DENTAL LACE ONE COULD SAY
THAT WAS POISONOUS TO BUT THAT
IS A VERY DIFFERENT. THE NATURE
OF IT IS VERY DIFFERENT- AND HOW
WE GET AT. BOTH REDUCING
PEOPLE'S USE OF THINGS THAT
COULD BE FENTANYL LACED FOR THE
IMPORT OF ANTI. THE SELLING OF
SENTINEL I THINK OUR THOSE ARE
VERY THOSE ARE WORTHWHILE THINGS
FOR US TO BE DEBATING AND
DISCUSSING BUT I THINK OUR- WHAT
HAS PROVEN IS THAT. WE HAVE
SIMILAR PENALTIES FOR SAY SALE
HERE ONE. SAILOR VARIOUS OTHER
SUBSTANCES SUBSTANCES AND IT HAS
NOT REDUCED THE SALE OF THE
SUBSTANCES. AND SO WHILE I
COMPLETELY I APPRECIATE THE VERY
LEGITIMATE STRONG AND NATURAL
DESIRE FOR ANYONE WHO HAD A
LOVED ONE FRIEND ANYONE THEY
WERE CLOSE TO WHO DIED FROM
FENTANYL ESPECIALLY THOSE
UNKNOWINGLY THAT THEY WANT
ACTION. I THINK THIS ACTION
ISN'T GOING TO GET US THE
REDUCTION THAT WE WOULD WANT. SO
I AND I HAD A LONG CONVERSATION
SOME EMAILS BACK AND FORTH A
LONG CONVERSATION WITH STAFF
ABOUT YOU KNOW WHAT ARE THE
APPROACHES THAT COULD ACTUALLY
GET. THIS STUFF OUT OF
CIRCULATION. AND I THINK WE
DON'T. AT LEAST WE DON'T HAVE AN
ANSWER FOR THAT YET- AND WHETHER
WHETHER THERE ARE STRATEGIES
THAT HAVE BEEN USED.
INTERESTINGLY I WAS IN PORTUGAL
IN OCTOBER THE ONLY TIME I'VE
TRAVELED IN THE LAST FEW YEARS
AND AT THE POINT I TRAVELED
THERE WAS AN OMICRON PRESENT AT
PORTUGAL HAD THE HIGHEST
VACCINATION RATES SO IT'S KIND
OF LIKE I HAD A LITTLE FANTASY
BLOOPERS. COVERT SAFETY BUT THE
POINT BEING IS THAT IN PORTUGAL
. WE MET WITH GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICIALS AND- LAW ENFORCEMENT
DRUG OFFICIALS IN PORTUGAL THEY
HAVE LEGALIZED THERE THE OPIOID
USE OR LEGALIZE IS NOT QUITE
RIGHT THEY HAVEN'T CRIMINALIZED
IT IN THE SAME WAY. AND WHILE
THEY HAVEN'T QUITE SAID IT'S
LEGAL THEY DON'T CRIMINALIZE IT
AND THEY PROVIDE- ON METHADONE
OR THEY PROVIDE FOR PEOPLE WHO
ARE AT AND- WE ASKED THEM ABOUT
THAT NO. BECAUSE CLEARLY THAT
KNOWS A WORLDWIDE PROBLEM. AND
THEY HAVE HAD VERY LITTLE
PRESENCE OF FENTANYL IN PORTUGAL
AND THERE ARE VERY FEW OVERDOSES
AND BECAUSE WHAT WE CALL
OVERDOSES IN MANY CASES ARE
REALLY A OPIOID DOES SPEND AWAY
FROM THE PERSON. DIES BECAUSE
THE FEDERAL. SO I WAS VERY
STRUCK THAT. NOW WHETHER WE
COULD ELIMINATE FAT NO WORD
MINIMIZE IT IN THAT WAY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA I DON'T KNOW WHETHER
WE HAVE THE APPETITE TO I DON'T
KNOW BUT I WAS VERY STRUCK BY
THE FACT THAT. PORTUGAL COMPARED
TO EUROPEAN COUNTRIES OTHER THAN
COMPARED TO US. HAS LITTLE TO NO
PRESENCE OF FENTANYL- SO WHY I
VERY MUCH. WHAT- GREENWAY.
TRYING TO IDENTIFY APPROACHES TO
GET THIS STUFF OUT OF
CIRCULATION ANSYS STOCK HAVING
PEOPLE POISONED AND DYING FROM
THIS BUT I DON'T THINK THE
APPROACH THAT'S BEING PRESENTED
TO US TODAY IT'S GOING TO KEEP
THE CALL. THAT YOU HAVE THAT I
WOULD HAVE BEEN THAT OF COURSE
THE PEOPLE WHO SUFFERED THE
STRATEGIES APPLE. THANK YOU
SENATOR CALM WATER THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I WANT TO- ALIGN
MYSELF WITH THE COMMENTS OF. MY
COLLEAGUES FROM BERKELEY AND SAN
FRANCISCO I AM ACTUALLY HAVE
BEEN THINKING A LOT ABOUT THEM
ALL- MOSTLY BECAUSE OF ALL OF
THE THINGS THAT I HAVE BEEN
READING IN THE PAPERS AND SEEING
ON THE NEWS ABOUT WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN LOS ANGELES- UPTAKE
IN DEATH. UPTICK IN YOUNG PEOPLE
USING FENTANYL- YOU KNOW
RECOGNIZING THAT YOU KNOW THE
SUPPLY CHAIN HAS TAKEN ITS TOLL
ON EVERYTHING FROM PEOPLE BEING
ABLE. TO PURCHASE THE RIGHT KIND
OF MATTRESSES AND PARTS FOR
THEIR CARS TO DRUGS YOU KNOW.
FENNEL IS CHEAP TO MANUFACTURE.
A WE HAVE INCREDIBLY POROUS
BORDERS- AND IT IS ENORMOUSLY
PROFITABLE. WE ARE AND ON TOP OF
THAT. WE HAVE A VERY
SCHIZOPHRENIC APPROACH TO. HOW
WE ACKNOWLEDGE. AND DEAL WITH
THE DRUG CULTURE THAT IS- YOU
KNOW ACROSS THIS COUNTRY. AND WE
HAVEN'T EVEN QUITE FIGURED OUT
HOW TO GRAPPLE WITH THE SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORMS THATALLOW FOR
THE SALE. OF DRUGS- I KNOW THAT
THERE WERE HEARINGS- IN DC ABOUT
THIS AND- TOOK A LITTLE AVAIL. I
WAS READING UP ON THIS BILL. AND
ALSO LOOKING AT CASES. A RELATED
TO FEDERAL AND OTHER RELATES TO
ENHANCEMENTS. THERE WAS SOMEONE
WHO A GENTLEMAN WAS CHARGED WITH
A TEN MILLION DOLLAR FINE AND
TEND TO LIE FOR POSSESSION
ANOTHER PERSON GOT THIRTY THREE
YEARS FOR POSSESSION ANOTHER MAN
GOT LIFE FOR TRAFFICKING. SO IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT CHARGES ARE
AVAILABLE AND THEY'RE USED IN
PEOPLE ARE GETTING- TIME AND
LOTS OF TIME. FOR EITHER THE
MANUFACTURE THE SALE OF THE
POSSESSION OF FENTANYL WHICH I
THINK IS WHAT THIS BILL IS
TRYING TO SPEAK TO SO I WONDER.
THEN THEN THE FASTER THE FOR
THIS. AND SUBSEQUENTLY I
ACTUALLY WONDER- AND SO AS A
RESULT OF THAT I DON'T KNOW IF
WE NEED SOMETHING LIKE THIS
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW IT WILL GET
TO THE HEART OF THE PROBLEM
SINCE WE ALSO HAVE TOOLS THAT
ARE BEING USED BY OUR
PROSECUTORS WITH REGARDS TO
FOLKS WHO ARE MANUFACTURING AND-
SELLING FENTANYL AND THERE ARE
SOME PROSECUTORS- ARE THERE SOME
DA'S IN CERTAIN COUNTIES WHO ARE
SAYING THAT THEY'RE GOING TO UP
pDEALERS SOLD SO THAT KIND OF
WORK IS ALREADY HAPPENING WITH
REGARDS TO- PUNISHMENT. I'M
ACTUALLY WONDERING WHAT WE CAN
DO TO GET TO THE HEART OF THE
ISSUE WHICH IS WHY FOLKS ARE
FEELING COMPELLED TO USE IT WHY
IT IS SO HOW DO WE CRACKED DOWN
ON MAKING IT LESS EASILY
AVAILABLE OR ATTRACTIVE- SO THAT
WE CAN HOPEFULLY PAVE IT. AND BE
PREPARED FOR THE NEXT WAVE OF
THE NEXT NEW AND CHEAPER AND
MORE DEADLY DRUGS. THAT WILL
PROBABLY COME TO US- AND THEN
WHAT CAN WE DO TO REALLY BUY
ACTRESS OUR COMMUNITIES AGAINST
THAT- AND I DON'T NECESSARILY
KNOW THAT THIS IS THE BILL FOR
THAT. BUT I AM WITH YOU WHEN
WOULD ACTUALLY LIKE TO BE
INVOLVED IN SOMETHING AS IT
RELATES TO DEALING WITH THE
ISSUE OF FEDERAL BECAUSE- YOU
KNOW WITH. IT'S KILLING
EVERYBODY YOU KNOW FOLKS WANT TO
HAVE A PARTY AND GET INTO
SOMETHING AND PRETEND THAT
THEY'RE SINGLE AND THEY TAKE A
DRUG AND IT'S GOT PHENYL AND
THEN. THEY DIE AND IT'S LIKE LOU
OR- YOUNG PEOPLE FEELING LIKE
THEY NEED SOME KIND OF COCKTAIL
AND THEY TAKE SOMETHING THAT HAS
IT AND THEN YOU KNOW SOMETHING
BAD HAPPENS- THE HEART OF IT IS
THE CARTELS IN THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE POROUS BORDERS AND THE FACT
THAT IT'S REALLY CHEAP TO
MANUFACTURE AND IT'S INCREDIBLY
SYMPATHETIC AND SO IT'S HARD
THAT. YOU KNOW SORT OF- IDENTIFY
SO I WOULD BE REALLY INTERESTED
IN SOMETHING LIKE THAT BUT
BECAUSE- PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
CHARGED AND HAVE BEEN
INCARCERATED FOR LIFE SENTENCES
I WONDER ABOUT THE NECESSITY FOR
THE ENHANCEMENT WHICH IS WHY I
AM HAVING TROUBLE SUPPORTING
THIS. PERIOD VERY INTERESTED IN
SOMETHING THAT CAN GET TO THE
HEART OF I THINK THE CONCERN
THAT ALL OF US HAVE BECAUSE IT'S
RAVAGING. REALLY ALL COMMUNITIES
AND- VERY INTERESTED IN WHAT WE
CAN DO BUT WONDERING ABOUT THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THIS
PARTICULAR- IDEA AND PROPOSAL.
YEAH BUT I DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S
A RESPONSE MAYBE EVEN FROM THE
WITNESS ABOUT THE FACT THAT
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN CHARGED AND
INCARCERATED EVEN FOR LIFE
SENTENCES FOR- THE SALE AND
POSSESSION OF CRIMINAL. ENTER TO
TALK TO CHARLOTTE. WELL I THINK
THAT'S A VERY INTERESTING-
RESEARCH THAT YOU DID ON THAT
TELEPHONE INTERCOM LONGER AND
I'D LIKE TO ASK OUR SHARE OF DON
BARNES MIGHT RESPOND TO THAT
SINCE THERE ARE THOSE WHO HAVE.
GOTTEN VERY THEORY OFFENSE BEING
OFF FOR INVOLVEMENT WITH THAT NO
ONE WAY OR THE OTHER AND I THINK
THAT YOUR. FARMS MIGHT STILL BE
ON THE LINE. ARE YOU THERE. YES
I AM AND I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE-
ALTHOUGH I DON'T AGREE WITH THE
DIRECTION I THINK THAT WE
SHOULDN'T BE YOU KNOW HONORED
SURPRISE NEXT YEAR WHEN THE
NUMBER KEEPS EDGES THAT DOUBLE
IT NOTHING IS BEING DONE- THE
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION WERE
FOCUSED ON END USERS NOT ON
DEALERS THEY FOCUS SPECIFICALLY
ON THE END USERS I'M ALL IN FOR
TREATMENT BY JILL HAS BETWEEN
FIVE AND FIFTEEN SEVEN TWENTY
FIVE PEOPLE IN MEDICINE ASSISTED
TREATMENT FOR OPIATE ADDICTION.
ON ANY GIVEN DAY AND WE'VE GONE
ALL IN ON TREATMENT FOR THOSE
WHO ARE SUFFERING ADDICTION
ISSUES AND I DON'T DISAGREE WITH
ANYBODY ABOUT GETTING PEOPLE
BACK ON THEIR FEET APPROPRIATELY
BUT THE DEFENDANT THING IS AT
THE FLAWED ARGUMENT FOR EXAMPLE
ONE KILO OF FENTANYL ALL ITS
EQUIPMENT OF FIFTY KILOS OF
OPIUM OR HEROIN. THE MAP BUT AT
THEIR TRAFFIC INTO TWO KILOS OF
HEROIN THAT WOULD BE IF THE
TWENTY YEAR SENTENCE UNDER
EXISTING LAWS IT'S CHEAP TO
PRODUCE. EASTER TRAFFIC. TAKING
THE DRUG OF CHOICE FOR TRAFFIC.
AND THE SENECA MARKER YOU
MEDICAL ABOUT WHAT WE'RE GONNA
DO THAT WHEN THE NEXT TWO TO
COMES WELL IT'S CALLED. IT'S ONE
HUNDRED TIMES MORE POTENT
FENTANYL WHICH IS FIFTY TIMES
MORE POTENT. THAN MORPHINE.
THEY'RE ALREADY THINKING THAT
SEARCH FOR THE NEW SEARCH- OF
CARFENTANIL. WHICH IS COMPLETELY
RESISTANT TO NALOXONE ORIGINAL
ROCKS ON PROGRAM IT'S AN OPEN
ATTACKING THIS. WITH MY
DEPARTMENT INTRODUCED IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN WITH WITH BOB
BOB FIRST PRESENT ABOUT
FENTANYL. ON THE WEST COAST
THROUGH MY CRIME LAB. AND I'VE
SAVED HUNDREDS OF LIVES AS A
RESULT OF BADAKHSHAN PROGRAM.
WHICH NUMBERS DO NOT GET COUNTED
ON THOSE OVERDOSE DEATH IN ABOUT
A MONTH FOR SOME AGENCIES. SO
THEY COULD AFFECT THE NUMBER
PROGRAM WITHIN THAT. I THINK IS
TROUBLING TO ME IS ALL OF YOU
HAVE TALKED ABOUT THE PUBLIC
HEALTH THE FASTER CENTER WIENER.
OFFENDERS CAN I CAN TELL YOU
THAT HEALTHCARE SYSTEM IS NOT
PROVIDING. IT THE MEDIC THAT THE
MEDICINE CONTROLLED MEDICAL
CONTROL STEPHANOPOULOS AND-
CONTROL FOR THOSE EXPERIENCING
YOU KNOW LAST CHAPTER THE RIGHT
USUALLY FOR CANCER- CONTROLLING
CANCER PAIN IT IS IN THE
HEALTHCARE ISSUE IT'S
CLANDESTINE PRODUCED. FENTANYL
COMING SOUTH OF THE BORDER. BY
THAT TIME AND IT'S GOING TO
CONTINUE TO DO SO. THE NARCOTICS
COME ACROSS THAT ARE.
CLANDESTINE PROTEST PILLS THAN
ACTS OXYCONTIN OXY CODE OWN. ARE
BEING TRAFFICKED. NOT LACED WITH
FENTANYL AS ONE OF THE SENATORS-
STAYED AT. YOU SENATOR WIENER
THAT'S NO PHARMACY QUALITY IN IT
THAT ONLY HAVE SPENT ABOUT. THAT
BEING SOLD AS A PHARMACEUTICAL.
THE RISK OF INCREASING YEAR TO
YEAR- THIS IS NOT A- WE'RE
CREATING NEW DEMAND BECAUSE
ACCORDING TO YOU ADDICTS. AND
THE SUPPLY CHAIN IS PERFECT AND
I WAS GOING THROUGH THE ROOF BUT
WE DID DO SOMETHING TO DISRUPT.
THE SUPPLY. AND DISCOURAGE.
PEOPLE FOR TRAFFICKING FENTANYL
WE SHOULD NOT BE SURPRISED NEXT
YEAR OR THE YEAR AFTER WHEN THE
NUMBERS CONTINUE TO DOUBLE.
CALIFORNIANS ARE DYING AT AN
EXPONENTIAL RATE THAT'S GOING
THROUGH THE ROOF. AND I BELIEVE
THE RIGHT THING TO DO IS TO RISK
A LOT TRY SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
HALF SB SEVEN FIVE LET'S SEE
THAT WILL DO TO. AT THE STOP
GAP. FOR THE DRUG TRAFFICKING
CPAS. TO FETCH UP FROM SOUTH OF
THE BORDER. THANK YOU. SENATOR
HOME WITH WHAT I. IN OF A OF TWO
OF- EXAMPLES YOU BROUGHT FOR
MIKE IS THAT FAN WITH WITH
HEROIN OR COCAINE YOU DO HAVE A
SENSE LIKE KIND OF A SOME OF
THAT SO THAT THE DOES RAISE UP
SO IF YOU LESS TEN. OF THE OF
FAT AND OR FAT NOW FOR A ONE
YARD THERE THEY'RE THEY'RE ON
THEIR WAY TO A LONGER YOU KNOW
NOT IN CARSON. OF I THINK THE
CONCERN THAT'S GROWING GROWING
IS THAT THIS WAS PURE FENTANYL
THAT'S COMING IN AND- YOU KNOW
HUGE QUANTITIES AND OF COURSE IF
THAT AVAILABLE THEN THEY'RE
GOING TO LACE IT INTO THESE
OTHER DRUGS THAT THEY'RE GOING
LAY FINANCIAL OR USUALLY THE
OPIOIDS. NOW FOR KIDS ARE
GETTING IT THEY'RE NOT GETTING
IT FROM HEROIN AND COCAINE ARE
GETTING IT FROM OXYCONTIN FOR
ONE OF THOSE SO THOSE ARE THE
ISSUES I THINK THAT REALLY THE
BILL NEEDS TO FOCUS ON- I AM
TOTALLY WILL FOR YOU ALL THE
EVIDENCE. MONTHS DO NOT THE
PLANT- TRUE- TREATMENT FOR
MENTAL HEALTH OR ADDICTION A
FEDERAL ABSOLUTELY THERE BUT
THERE'S A PLACE FOR SENTIMENT
HELL SPENCER WOULD HAVE BEEN
THERE FOR HEROIN AND COCAINE IF
IT WASN'T WORKING FOR THOSE
LIQUID LIQUID FENTANYL DOING NOW
IT'S MAKING NORTH. SECONDARY
DRUGS AND YOU KNOW AND- IT'S
BECOME THE DRUG OF CHOICE
BECAUSE THEY GET YOUR HIGH
FASTER BUT IF NIKI THE WAY OF
COMING IN AND AFFECTING OUR
YOUNGER POPULATION AND THOSE WHO
ARE ALREADY ADDICTED AND NEED TO
GET HIGHER AND HIGHER AND THESE
FELLOWS WHO ARE- TELLS ME THEY
KNOW. I DO BELIEVE THAT YOU'RE A
BARNES MADE A REALLY GREAT POINT
AT A PANEL I PARTICIPATED IN
ABOUT A MONTH AGO THAT UNTIL WE
STOP THE DEMAND WE'RE NOT GOING
TO STOP THE IMPORTATION OF THE
PRODUCTION BECAUSE IT FULL. OF
BLUE GRILL BUT IF WE START WITH
SOMETHING THAT BOTH. USE YOUR
BRAIN THOUGHT IN PURELY ONE KILO
IS TWO POUNDS YOU KNOW FIVE KILO
TEN POUNDS AND ON AND ON AND I
THOUGHT COMING IN WE'RE NOT
COMING IN A LITTLE PLASTIC BAG
BECAUSE THEY'RE DISTRIBUTING ON
THE STREET. SO THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO REIN IN I I'M OPEN TO
US CONTINUING THE DISCUSSION. OR
MAYBE THERE'S A WAY TO START
WITH THIS BILL UP WITH. IN THE
FINANCE. MAYBE WE SAW. THE SEVEN
HEY MONTHS FOR COCAINE AND
HEROIN. TAKE THOSE OUT PUT HIM
ON THERE FOR FAT. DO WE IF WHICH
AN OUTER MAYBE SHOULD BE A- PRO
THAT DOES SOMETHING. TO TRY TO
GET TO WHAT SENATOR. WITH SAYING
THAT BEEN ABLE TO DO PORTUGAL.
WELL WE'RE ALL LOOKING FOR AN
ANSWER- THIS. TO DO. HELP R. P.
GET ALL. OF WHATEVER A GIFT
PERSON. OF HOW THEY WERE GOT
INTO A BIT ON THE OTHER FOR. WE
HAVE LOTS OF. THOSE WHO. REALLY
VERY INVOLVED IN MAKING MILLIONS
AND MILLIONS OF DOLLARS- BECAUSE
WE DON'T HAVE A WAY TO FOCUS ON
THEM AND WHAT THEY'RE DOING. AND
WE KNOW THAT THEY KNOW THEY'VE
GOT A FAST TRACK AN EASY STREET
TO GET THAT STUFF IN HERE. AND
THEN GIVE IT TO THE PEOPLE THAT
PUT IT IN THESE OTHER OTHER
DRUGS. SO THAT'S WHY I KEEP
BRINGING IT BACK. IN I THINK WE
NEED TO HAVE AN ONGOING DIFFER.
AND I'D LOVE TO HAVE YOUR I.
VOTE TODAY. I DON'T SEE THAT
IT'S NECESSARILY THERE. BUT I
KNOW THAT YOUR HEART THROUGH
THERE AND I THINK YOUR
COMMITMENT TO TRY TO. MAKE THIS
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN BE PROUD
OF IN THE NEXT FIVE YEARS THAT
WE RAN THE WHOLE THING YEAH. IT
WOULD BE A BOON ON TO OUR STATE.
MAYBE WE COULD BE THE LEADER IN
THERE BECAUSE IT'S CERTAINLY
SOMETHING THAT PLAGUING. OUR
NATION. SO WITH THAT I ASKED
YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU SOONER
COMMA. THANK YOU SENATOR I DO
WANTED TO RESPOND BECAUSE I
PULLED THE UP THE- ACTUALLY THE
PERSON WHO GOT THIRTY THREE
YEAR. HELLO WAS WAS WAS WAS.
THEY WERE CONVICTED BECAUSE THEY
GAVE SOMEONE ONE DOES. AND THEN
THE PERSON WHO GOT LIFE- HAD- A
LESS THAN A KILO. SO I SAY THAT
BECAUSE IT'S THERE'S A LOT OF
DISCREPANCY AND- VARIANCE IN HOW
FOLKS ARE BEING CHARGED BUT I
THINK IT DOES GO TO THE FACT
THAT THERE ARE TOOLS THAT ARE
OUT THERE. AND I THINK THE FOLKS
WHO ARE ON THE STREET WHO ARE
SELLING IN- INCONSEQUENTIAL TO
THE LARGER PROBLEM WHICH ARE THE
CARTELS AND JUST THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY THAT CAN BE. MADE SELLING
THIS AND SO HOW DO WE FIGURE OUT
A WAY TO GO TO THE HEART OF IT
BECAUSE IF YOU TAKE YOU KNOW A-%
PERSON A OFFICE. PERSON B. OR C.
OR D. ARE RIGHT AROUND THE
CORNER. AS LONG AS THERE ARE
ABLE TO. AS LONG AS PROFITS ARE
ABLE TO BE MADE. AND IT IS CHEAP
. TO PRODUCE THEN WE DON'T IT'S
LIKE WHACK A MOLE AND I THINK WE
OWE IT TO THE STATE AND THE
FOLKS WHO ARE COMING IN CONTACT
WITH THE DRUG FIGURE OUT A WAY
TO GET TO THE HEART OF IT BUT IT
SEEMS LIKE BECAUSE THERE ARE
FOLKS WHO HAVE BEEN PROSECUTED
AND CHARGED AND SENTENCED. THAT
PROSECUTORS ARE FINDING TOOLS
TOGETHER WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
ANOTHER WAY TO ATTACK THE
PROBLEM- BUT I JUST WANTED TO
SHARE THAT THERE'S A LOT OF
DISCREPANCY WITH REGARDS TO HOW
MUCH OF THE FENTANYL WAS IN THE
POSSESSION OF THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
CHARGED AND THEN FENTON. SO I
JUST WANT TO RAISE THAT BECAUSE
I. AND I DON'T WANT A LOT OF
BACK AND FORTH BUT I'M JUST
SHARING THIS BECAUSE I WANT YOU
TO KNOW. THAT THIS IS I MEAN I
CARE ABOUT THIS TOO. AND I WANT
TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO GET TO
THE HEART OF WHAT THE THING IS-
SO. I WE LOOK AT IT IS THAT YOU
KNOW THE POISON WE HAVE RAT
POISON AFFECTING OUR- YOU KNOW
OF MELAMINE POPULATION WE
IMMEDIATELY JUMP TO THIS IS
POISON THAT'S AFFECTING OUR
PEOPLE. WE'VE GOT TO FIND AN
ANSWER WE WOULDN'T HAVE ANY
PROBLEM- PASSING BILLS THAT STOP
POISONOUS POISONING OUR FOOD
POISONING OUR CROPS. PLEASING
OUR ANIMALS LIVE WITH POLICE IN
OUR PEOPLE AND I THINK WE HAVE
TO LOOK AT IT THAT WAY AND- KIND
OF GO DOWN THAT PATH. AND KIND
OF GET IT OUT OF THE- PUBLIC
SAFETY ISSUE. AND ON CUE IT IS A
SUBSTANCE THAT REALLY NEEDS TO
NOT. TO NOT BE ABLE TO BE
PRODUCED AND TRAFFIC DOWN NOW
BROUGHT IN HERE AND TRUCKLOAD
FULL. WITHOUT I'LL BE BACK TO
YOU GUYS I KNOW YOU ALL WANT TO
FIND AN ANSWER. AND I WANT TO BE
PART OF THAT WITH YOU COOL THANK
YOU WE HAVE CENTER- CHEWABLE.
THANK YOU MISS CHAIRMAN VERSE.
THANK YOU FOR THE PROPERTY TO
SPEAK. I WOULD FIRST LIKE TO
EXPRESS MY GRATITUDE TO THE
OPERATR FOR HER TIRELESS
EFFORTS ON THIS IMPORTANT NOW IN
THE COMMENTS THAT MY COLLEAGUES
ARE CHEERING ON THE SCIENCE. AS
WELL NOW THE PENDULUM HAS BEEN
MANAGING THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
REGION IN RECENT YEARS. THIS IS
THIS YOUR HOME IN S. T. AT
THREE. ARE THERE WERE TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN THAT'S AN
OLD RELATED DEATHS IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY IN TWENTY TWENTY WELL.
AND IN RECENT MONTHS 50% OF ALL
OVERDOSE DEATHS IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY HAVE BEEN ATTRIBUTED TO
SENTINEL. AS MENTIONED EARLIER.
THERE WAS A RISE OF 656% THAT'S
EXAMINE YOUR PARENTS. AT I THINK
OKAY THANK YOU FOR. TO BE FIFTY
MORE THAN. AND YOU DON'T-
OVERDOSE OCCUR AND AMERICA FOUND
OF. I THE USER DRUGS HAVE NO
KNOWLEDGE. NO KNOWLEDGE THAT THE
DRUGS THERE CONSUMING CONTAIN
THE OF. THE PARTS HAVE LOST MY
OR HIS. THERE IS NO DOUBT THAT
THIS DEADLY DRUG FENTANYL
INVOLVED ON THE LIST. THESE ARE
. ROUTES IT ALSO NOTING THAT
THIS WOULD NOT TARGET SUBSTANCE
ABUSERS. OR EVEN INDIVIDUALS
GENERALLY SELLING DRUGS AS THE
QUANTITY SO LARGE THAT IT WOULD
ONLY APPLY TO INDIVIDUALS
TRANSPORTING MASSIVE AMOUNTS OF
PRODUCT FOR DISTRIBUTION. AND IT
GOES THAT- IF ALL ELSE IS WOULD
BE JUST A SMALL STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION TOWARDS
ADDRESSING THE EPIDEMIC AND EVEN
MORE SO IT'S NOT A RIGHT
DIRECTION WORK OUT IN YOUR INBOX
BUT PERHAPS THE STATEMENT BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE TO
SAY. ENOUGH IS ENOUGH. AND I'M
NOT MOTION NINE HUDSON'S. IS
THAT WHAT YOUR PROFITS. THANK
YOU. AND SIR ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION DEBATE BY COLLEGE
HERE IN CHINA I TOO JUST WANNA-
STATE MY APPRECIATION FOR YOUR
COMMITMENT TO THIS ISSUE AND- BY
NO MEANS WANT TO DIMINISH THE
EFFORT THAT YOU HAVE MADE. OVER
THE YEARS TO BRING THIS TO AN
END- COOL NOT ONLY THE
LEGISLATORS ATTENTION BUT
CALIFORNIA INTONATION AS WELL
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE DYING FROM
THIS BUT AGAIN HAS CLEARLY BEEN
DEMONSTRATED OVER THE LAST FORTY
YEARS ON THE WAR ON DRUGS
ENHANCEMENTS DO NOT. DETER
INDIVIDUALS FROM DOING CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY REGARDS OR WHAT IS
WE'VE JUST SEEN THAT FROM TIME
AND TIME AGAIN. AND I THINK ESR
CALM WATER WHICH- REFERENCING AS
WE SAW FORTY YEARS AGO WITH THE
CRACK. EPIDEMIC THE CARTELS WERE
VERY RARELY IMPACTED IT WAS
ALWAYS THE FRONTLINES. STREET
SELLER WHO HAD A GRAMMAR TO
MAYBE AN OUNCE AND THEY WERE THE
ONES IN SUMMER PRICE STILL
IMPRISONED TODAY- BUT THE
CARTELS HAVE MOVED ON FROM
COCAINE NOW TO FENTANYL AND-
TRUE ENOUGH WE NEED TO STOP THE
MANUFACTURING DAY. IMPORTING
WITH THE TRAFFICKING IN THIS
DEADLY DISEASE I MEAN DEADLY
DRUG BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THEIR- ADDICTION
IS A DISEASE TOO AND I JUST WISH
WE COULD. FIND A WAY TO. HAVE A
MORE HEALTH CENTERED APPROACH TO
HELPING THOSE INDIVIDUALS
BECAUSE AGAIN THE MAJORITY OF
THOSE FIT FOLKS ARE DYING FROM
THIS ONE ON ONE WITH A SINGLE
LIFE BUT THE MAJORITY ARE NOT.
BINDING FROM FRONTLINE COURT
CARTEL SELLERS THERE'S- THEIR
FRIENDS. IN SCHOOL MATES AND-
JERRY DRUGS AMONGST EACH OTHER
IN A PARTY ENVIRONMENT AND
GETTING BAD DRUGS UNBEKNOWNST TO
THEM AND UNFORTUNATELY LOSING%
THEIR LIVES SO. I'M JUST WARNING
AS TO WHAT'S BEST TO DO HERE WE
OFFERED UP SOME AMENDMENTS
RECOMMENDING. ME INTO SUCH A
SEPARATE STATUTE- DEALING WITH
MENTAL AND WHAT WERE YOU ON
CONSIDERING THAT AND JUST.
DEALING WITH IT AND CLEARLY AS
IT RELATES TO SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT HAVE BEEN MENTIONED HERE TO
TRAFFICKING- IMPORT IMPORTING
AND TRANSPORTATION AND SELLING
OUT- DRUG.
WELL WE DO NOT HAVE A
COPY OF ANYTHING IT CAME
DESCRIBING THE NEMESIS THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THEY DIDN'T GERMAN
RAPPER BUT WE HAD- THE TOTAL-
COLVIN IN FACT INFESTATION IN
OUR OFFICE SO POSSIBLY. WE MISS
THAT INFORMATION. SO IF IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WOULD PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE OUR
DISCUSSION ON THE BILL AND HAVE
IT. YOU WORK IN PROGRESS I WOULD
OBVIOUSLY BE VERY OPEN TO THAT.
AN IONIZER I STAND CORRECTED WE
DID NOT OFFER A MULTI YEAR SO
IT'S BEEN A DISCUSSION SO- I
MISSPOKE THERE BUT- THERE WAS
DISCUSSION ABOUT POSSIBLE
AMENDMENTS THAT COULD. MAKE
THIS- MORE ACCEPTABLE TO-
MEMBERS HERE ON THIS COMMITTEE
BUT IMPORTANT HEPS WE CAN START
THERE AND WITH THAT DISCUSSION
AND THEN IT'S A NEW IT'S A NEW
YEAR AND I'LL BE TALKING TO
SENATOR COM LAGER AND- SENATOR
SKINNER AND SENATOR WIENER AND
HAVE SOME CONVERSATION MAYBE
THEY CAN GIVE SOME IDEAS TO LOOK
LIKE. I THINK THERE'S SOMETHING
THERE THAT WE'RE ALL CONCERNED
ABOUT THERE'S SOMETHING THERE
THERE'S A THERE THERE- WE'VE GOT
TO FIND IT AND I WANT TO BE
COMMITTED TO DO THAT FOR WHAT I
DID IT WITHOUT A DOUBT. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. YES I DO
THANK YOU FOR THE DISCUSSION I
APPRECIATE IT- AND- I ASKED FOR
AND I VOTE I HAVE. A MOTION
ANYWAY SO. OKAY THANK YOU. MAN
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON AS P. SEVENTY FIVE THREE
SEVEN FIVE DAY PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BRADFORD ABOUT.
FRAUD FOR NOT VOTING INTRO BUGS
I- ABOUT GUY COME OVER I'M GOING
TO COME ARE NOT VOTING SCANNER.
AND ARE NOT VOTING WINNER.
WINNER NOW THAT'S ONE TO ONE.
SENATOR TWENTY ONE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION AND- THANK YOU
GUYS OKAY THANK YOU. MEASURE
FAILS. WE YEAH AND THEN THE NEXT
TIME IT'S JUST- VOTE ONLY AND
IT'S- S. E. THREE FIFTY. IS
THERE A MOTION FOR S. THREE
FIFTY. IT'S BEEN MOVED. MADAM
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON S. V. THREE FIFTY THREE FIFTY
THE PASTOR PREPARATION BRADFORD
NO REDFORD NOTRE BUGS. START
YOUR OWN MUTE IT'S NOT THAT
MELINDA SPELL AT THE THREE FIFTY
. I CAN. ME ON MUTE SENATOR
MELINDA SMITH SENATOR MILLER
THIS YEAR AND- TROUBLE I'M SORRY
COULD YOU REPEAT THAT ONE MORE
TIME IT'S NOT I IT'S S. B. THREE
FIFTY MELENDEZ'S BILL. SO IT
SHOULD WE'RE VOTING ON IT'S
ABOUT ONLINE. THIS ITEM FOR ITEM
FOR. THE TROUBLE WE'RE ASKING
FOR YOUR VOTE ON SB THREE FIFTY
VOTE ONLY. MELINDA ON MELINDA'S
YEAH BUT. MAYBE IF YOU CAME HERE
. CAN YOU HEAR US AND- DROBO CAN
YOU HEAR US. SENATOR OCHO A BOG
CAN YOU HEAR US. YOU HEAR
SENATOR. I. SO I AM A LENDERS AS
B. THREE FIFTY. CORRECT YEAH.
CAN YOU STATE WHAT YOU'VE
ALREADY ION SENATOR WILL TROUBLE.
SIR CAN YOU HEAR IS. CENTER TO
A BOAT CAN YOU STATE YOUR VOTE
ON SB THREE FIFTY. YES SENATOR
OR SHOW UP- SP THREE FIFTY NINE
THANK YOU. THE TROUBLE BUT I'D
COME LONGER NO LONGER NO SCANNER
SCANNER NO WINNER WINNER NUMBER
ONE TO FOR THE MAJORS WON THE
FOUR THAT MEASURE FAILS. I THINK
THAT CONCLUDES OUR AGENDA FOR
TODAY J.
INCLUDES OUR AGENDA FOR
THE DAY I WANT TO THANK.
EVERYONE FOR THEIR PARTICIPATION
AND- OKAY AND I THINK FOR THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATE IN
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF
YOU ARE UNABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY
POLICE IMAGE YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS AND RIDING. TO THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE OR VISIT
OUR WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS THANK YOU AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR EVERYONE
WHOSE- FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
YOUR COOPERATION AND THIS
CONCLUDES OUR AGENDA THE SENATE
PUBLIC. SIXTY COMMITTEE AND WE
STAND ADJOURNED.